so much love happening in music city and
for nicole kidman and keith urban it was
also a much needed date night
[Applause]
[Music]
don't you two look like a vision tonight
nice to be getting dressed up for once
isn't it not from just here
what are you looking forward to most
about his performance this evening i
will be singing and dancing because
that's what i do anyplace it is she's
your ultimate hype girl keith that's for
sure
cannot wait seeing you portray lucy what
an iconic role sorry
i got lost for a second
was it just a dream role to take on
nicole it was really really hard but i
just completely fell in love with her
and when i say got to know her i mean
studied all of her work and and also got
to know her daughter really well
[Music]
country boy blake performing in front of
a windmill hit the cmas without gwen she
was home with the kids after he helped
her wrap up her vegas residency last
weekend
miranda lambert set the stage on fire
celebrating her 38th birthday by opening
the show she and hubby brennan
mclaughlin matched in black on the red
carpet are you going to keep the party
going with the hubs and your friends
after the cma yes i'm hoping to
celebrate over tacos margaritas
that's brandon gushing over his wife at
the after party an eyewitness tells us
miranda was blushing the entire time
next did carrie underwood throw hosts
luke bryan a little side eye that look
happened after luke seemed to take a jab
at aaron rodgers all my fellow artists
tested and together
poor immunized
yeah i've been immunized
well carrie who performed if i didn't
love you is apparently on team erin she
recently liked her husband's post
supporting the quarterback
katy perry and lionel richie helped luke
hand out the first award which went to
chris stapleton he won the night with
four trophies and performed an aretha
franklin tribute with jennifer hudson
[Applause]
other big winners honey i'm getting used
to this female vocalist of the year
carly pierce who kissed her boyfriend
riley king before accepting brothers
osbourne
in nine months after publicly coming out
t.j osborne celebrated his cma win with
his boyfriend i just felt completely
accepted and loved by my peers
luke combs and wife nicole also shared a
sweet kiss as he pulled off the night's
biggest surprise entertainer of the year
has a really nice ring to it doesn't it
i don't deserve to win it
but i'm sure as hell glad that i did
thank you all so much
how are you and wife he's celebrating
today
we're gonna have some drinks for sure
go get some fast food
like sun like mother
thomas red celebrating two with his date
mom paige this is your first red carpet
pretty yes doing this absolutely wife
lauren was m.i.a expecting baby girl
number four she's about to give birth
yeah i mean it literally i'm waiting on
the phone call to be honest no way see
we're just going to keep going until
we go to the hospitals
[Music]
he got a standing o just like mickey
guyton brady spencer and madeline
edwards making cma history with their
celebration of black hair no i'm not
scared
to love who i am this is something this
crowd has not seen before it was such a
beautiful moment what we went through
to get on that stage
[Applause]
jimmy allen
after 10 years of
being here living in my car uh this is
amazing and there was more emotion on
stage and off jimmy i was over here
crying hear me both i'm still emotional
these ain't new tears these tears from
before just for the record these ain't
new tears they left over tears
hey how you celebrating tonight
[Applause]
[Music]